quanis by Daniel a douche from the CWI
and absolutely all right thank you very
much so I'll talk today about
approximating covering radius finding
dense lattice subspaces and how it all
relates to integer program so the
outline at talk is I'm going to talk
first about integer programming open
question there how algorithms for IP
worst-case algorithms work and its
relationship to a conjecture that's
called the canonical bus conjecture that
will be probably the semi understandable
part of the talk and then we will move
on to the mostly incomprehensible part
of the talk which will be about
adventures in trying to prove it
okay so integer programming classic
problem we want to minimize over the
integer points inside a polytope and the
big open question at least from the
perspective of this talk is can we solve
this in singly exponential time and
those actually we already mentioned last
week there is an end to the order n time
algorithm for this and it's due to
cannot so let me tell you roughly how
these algorithms work with a kind of
updated perspective that in fact comes
from my thesis which I'll point you to
at least a bottleneck that that one can
hope to improve so there are two cases
this is sort of a dichotomous situation
and when you're trying to solve IP so
here I'm just gonna try and find a
feasible integer point not maximized but
it's not much different so the first
case is like if you have your buddy K
and it's like super big okay and they're
like sort of clearly tons of lattice
points inside this and the way in which
we quantify that is in terms of the
covering radius of the body so the
covering radius of the body is the
minimum scaling such that no matter
where I shift it I still intersect the
integers okay so now I mean you can you
can check that in fact this is sort of
the worst case I should scale it down by
2/3 and
if I scale it down any further I'm not
going to contain lattice points in every
possible shift okay so in this case this
is somehow the easy case when the body
is like really big and fat it turns out
we can find the integer points inside
here and singly exponential time so this
is not the hard part the hard part is
when this is not the situation and so
when it's not the situation the covering
radius is somehow big and this is when
we say that sort of K is flat in some
way shape or form and sort of the most
general way of quantifying when how that
could how that could be good and this
may be something that many of you have
not seen formalized this way is that if
it's flat it turns out that there should
be an integral projection of some
dimension which I'm not going to specify
such that the volume of the projection
is small so to do this for a
one-dimensional projection here is the
projection onto the y-axis and you can
see that here the volume is 2 okay
and this volume is 2 in fact will
roughly correspond to sort of the number
of fibers of this projection that could
possibly correspond to feasible points
upstairs and usually the goal is to sort
of recurse on all of these subproblems
and in my thesis sort of what I showed
is that you can basically recurse on all
of these subproblems in time that's sort
of proportional to this volume ok and
the reason we normalize the volume by
the power 1 over K is because here I'm
sort of killing K dimensions of the
problem at this cost which is sort of
the effective branch this is like the
effective branching factor okay so those
are the two dichotomous situations now
the question is you know what what is
going on with this quantity so it turns
out that this quantity is in fact so
this is sort of the best possible
projection there is a direct duality
relationship between it and the covering
radius okay so this left-hand side it
turns out it's easy I will prove the
special case of it later and this is the
hard side ok so this is what control
the branching factor of your integer
program and one interesting thing is to
think about this and I mean that'll come
up later that these guys so this
projection matrix is to some extent an
efficiently checkable certificate that
the covering radius itself is large
okay just using the easi site good so we
have flatness theorems that quantify how
flat the the body can be in this case
and the first case that we studied was
in the case where the the rank of the
projection is 1 so it's really just an
integer vector okay and here after a lot
a lot of work come up here we've been
able - oh or people you know many
researchers have been able to show that
you can bound it by a polynomial in
dimension so this is basically the
branching factor and and you get this
sort of n to the 4/3 times some poly
logarithms ok
and there is a conjecture that in fact
the correct right hand side should not
be poly you know and to the 4/3 it
should just be N and if that's the case
then it's tight you can just take like a
simplex scale it up by N and convince
yourself that that's a tight example ok
great so we have tons of dimensions that
we could play with why play with just
one ok so what happens if you play with
more dimensions so if you don't restrict
yourself to finding a Rank 1 integer
projection then it turns out that there
is a actually a remarkably easy proof I
mean I'm not going to say it's it's not
that easy but it's it's much easier than
the previous proof that the sort of
effective branching factor you get this
way is bounded by n ok so n is better
than n to the 4/3 the branching factor
still polynomial we're still going to
get things like n to the order n time
why do we care so the conjecture is that
in fact the truth should be much much
better and possibly the right-hand side
so the effective branching factor should
be even logarithmic in dimension or poly
logarithmic ok
so they can be computed I have an
algorithm to compute these things in
like horrendous complexity which is more
horrible than than the complexity of IP
but you will see later that that yeah
you'll see later oh I'll talk more about
it but they are to some extent
computable okay so the right right hand
side also cannot be smaller than login
and there's a very nice counter example
all these I mean tight example and all
these examples are very simple they're
all like scalings of the simplex somehow
these conjectures are sort of difficult
for like stupid looking examples good so
what is the conclusion is that in fact
if the conjecture were true and you
could somehow magically compute this
thing and let's say singly exponential
time then okay instead of n to the N you
would get log into the end and we would
all be very happy and call it a day so
so you know of course you know if things
could fly we could do anything so is
this true in any you know situation ok
so the main question that we tried to
solve was is this conjecture at least
true in the case where your body is an
ellipsoid and this is a like not a
simple case I mean as you'll as you'll
see and the answer to this question as
was answered by reg of and Stephens do
it dividuals is yes ok so it turns out
that in fact if you restrict your bodies
to being ellipsoids the conjecture is
true and can we compute the projection
so in fact the previous result that I
just mentioned was an existential result
and it turns out in this talk I can show
that yes you can indeed compute the
projection in single exponential so
let's go to the second part of the talk
where I will probably start losing many
of you so just ask me questions and
probably
I get to roll my slide something went
horribly wrong so so stop me so we're
gonna talk about algorithms and
refinements of the conjecture in the
case of ellipsoids we should call the l2
case okay so it turns out that it's you
know much better for your health to not
think about ellipsoids yes okay good
point yes so for ellipsoids we know how
to do everything in a different way but
this is hopefully going to generalize
right so the point is that techniques
that we come up with here are very
different and you know seem like they
get us non-trivial II close to the
general case okay so that's that's a
good point we do know how to do
everything in single exponential m4
ellipsoids alright so it turns out that
it's much easier for your health to sort
of fold the geometry into the lattice so
transform your lipslide into a ball and
now instead of the integer lattice you
have a linear transformation of the
integer lattice okay so then instead of
all the geometries sort of folded into
the lattice so what our lattice is okay
so this is the integer lattice that's
what we were looking at before more
generally you can take integer linear
combinations of any basis okay o RN and
here you can see that there many
different ways of specifying the same
lattice and the quantity of crucial
importance for us today is the
determinant which if you take any basis
it's the volume of the fundamental
parallelepiped but even more importantly
it's also equal to the volume of any
region the tile space with respect to
the lattice okay so any region the TEL
space with respect to a lot us is
exactly the same volume and so it's it's
a it's a invariant a useful invariant so
now let's kind of do some translation
and try and restate everything in the
context of sort of l2 and lattices and
here I'll be able to show some of the
simple proofs that I skipped before so
the covering radius is just now going to
be the kind of farthest distance away
from the lattice I can be
right that's that's the covering radius
and if you look at this beautiful object
notice the Voronoi cell so this is all
the points that are closer to the origin
than anyone else you can see that the
covering radius is exactly the smallest
ball that I need to contain the Voronoi
cell okay so now let's try and reprove
these kind of volumetric lower bounds
that I claimed were the easy side that
we didn't see last time and so they
really all stem from the kind of trivial
fact that this ball has to have at least
the same volume as the Voronoi cell
right and importantly the Voronoi cell
because it's a tiling region has volume
equal to the determinant and so if you
move everything around and you remember
that volume is sort of an homogeneous in
in in RN you will get this lower bound
on the covering radius okay
but now there were all these projections
and things going on in the in in the in
the previous part of the talk so where
are they here so it comes from okay so
this by the way notation is just like
I'm ignoring constant factors okay so
this is roughly what the bound is okay
so I'm bringing back in projections so
now let me use this nice notation to say
that I can project the lattice onto a
subspace W and I mean orthogonal
projections shrink Euclidean distances
so if you think about it the covering
radius after I shrink should get smaller
right so if the covering radius after I
shrink should get smaller then I can
sort of apply the lower bound here and
get a new lower bound here okay so that
gives me this alright and now I can sort
of maximize over all of these lower
bounds and this is essentially the the
kind of dual quantity of what I showed
you before but it's basically you know
the best possible volumetric lower bound
you can get for the covering radius good
so what is the l2 version of the sort of
kanaan Lovis conjecture
is so somehow this we know is a lower
bound but is it also an upper bound
right so that's really the question and
this number is is you know by by how
much are we off okay
so also it's easy to see in this
particular case that okay square root of
log n so anything when you do things in
l2 you get square roots so square root
of log n is in fact the best possible
and again it's a very simple example
it's just like a scaling of the integer
lattice so what is it that is that is
known okay so in in 88 canal of loss
when they worked on this they showed
that this constant for l2 is bounded by
square root of n which is better than n
which they had for the general case and
basically that was it until last year
and last year Oh dead leg of and I
showed that if you assume a conjecture
that maybe I will have time to talk
about at the end then in fact this
number is bounded by a polygon and then
this year at stalk reg Evan and Noah
Stephens Davidowitz proved this rumor
Smith Kowski conjecture and slightly
improved our reduction and showed that
in fact for l2 this is bounded by a log
to the three halves alright so now I
mean the rest of the talk is going to be
talking about refinements of what was
going on there so any questions so far
the reverse Niko's characters it's so I
will I will set it at the end hopefully
but basically the point is revert and
minkowski's theorem tells you that a
lower bound of the number of lattice
points in terms of sub lattice
determinants okay or in terms of lattice
determinants so if your determinants too
small you should have a lot of lattice
points and reverse Mankowski is the
opposite so if all your determinants are
big can you upper bound the number of
lattice points so good all good so far
okay so what do we show so first as I
mentioned there is kind of an
algorithmic aspect that was missing in
the previous result so we show that you
can actually find this subspace with
it's a bit worse it's not like log n to
the three halves but it's log into the
2.5 but I guess still good enough for
government work and in singly
exponential time now what's the the
second thing that we show or that I show
okay and how does this compare to the
prior work so I mean in in the paper of
Canal of us they use if people know in
hkz basis and now we know how to compute
hkz bases in 2 to the n times so somehow
that was already algorithmic I showed
with Danielle amici on show that if you
want to compute the best possible
subspace I mean I don't care what this
bound is but I'm just the best possible
subspace then I can do it in a decreased
amount of time and that also extends to
general convex bodies the thing that was
the question that us but this we can do
better good and the second thing and
this is was at least to me very
surprising is that you you can do better
than just use projections projection
determinants to get a lower bound on the
covering radius of the lattice so if you
only use projection determinants you are
stuck with square root log n as a lower
bound but it turns out if you're a
little bit more careful you can get
within a constant factor so you can get
a lower bound that is tight within a
constant factor assuming the slicing
conjecture for Voronoi cells so what on
earth is the slicing conjecture I mean I
guess it doesn't really matter because
I'm not gonna get much into it but
basically it says if you have a newborn
myself and has volume one then it should
have a slice of lower bounded constant
volume okay so that's the slicing
conjecture for my cells okay so now we
will get to probably the completely
unintelligible part of the talk so now
I'll tell you sort of a lot of the the
kind of new techniques that came in to
proving this but only at a very kind of
floozie level so the first thing well
actually
okay yeah so so first things some
notation if I have a sub lattice then
you know and it's empty then the
convention is the determinant is one
also because there's a lot of normalized
determinants that are going to appear
everywhere let me just use this to
shortcut that so that makes the notation
less horrible and if I write this
notation it is not L quotient adem that
would be probably the more reasonable
thing but instead it is L projected
orthogonal to M okay the span of M so
this is going to be the projections and
and it'll be helpful all right so so I
said new but in fact this is from 76
it's just that none of us knew about it
well except for Stewart and it's really
beautiful and basically what's to ler
and and company showed so these are
people who are interested in the
questions that I don't even understand
in the reduction theory of quadratic
forms they looked at this amazing object
that's called the canonical polytope and
what it is is you have a lattice it's in
dimensions you draw the scatterplot with
so you have coordinates that index
dimension from 0 to n at 0 you put the
point 0 0 at n you put the point n comma
log determinant to the hell
and everywhere else you put points at K
comma log Det M where n is any sub
lattice of dimension K okay and now what
you look at is the kind of lower convex
hull of this this poly tope so we're
interested in in this line okay and this
will turn out to be the correct way to
break up your lattice into pieces and
what is amazing about this thing and
people who know about you know things
like determinant being look so modular
maybe not so impressed by this but I was
is that if you look at the vertices of
this so you look at the lattices that
correspond to the vertices of this these
form a chain okay so they're nested one
inside each other and yeah well I'll get
to the remaining properties in a second
but they form a chain and they're unique
good and the important thing nice thing
is that the sort of slopes that you see
here correspond to normalized
determinants so they're little
normalized determinants of blocks so
slope equals determinate or normalize
determinant so an N dimensional lattice
is stable if its canonical filtration
which was this thing that correspondent
to the chain is trivial which means that
this lower convex hull is just a
straight line okay and what this means
is that there's sort of no dense sub
lattices lying in your lattice one
example you take the integer lattice the
minimum determinants that you get for
every dimension just correspond to
coordinate projections so they all have
determinant one meaning the log is zero
so this is the line that you get for the
integer lattice okay so it is stable it
it has trivial canonical filtration why
are these useful good oh yeah some
properties that I forgot to mention so I
said these guys form a chain it turns
out that the blocks themselves are stay
which you can kind of see from the
picture that like this is a straight
line which is what I was saying about
stability and the slopes are increasing
meaning these kind of normalize
determinants of blocks are going up good
so why are these useful so first it
turns out that the fundamental block
that makes sense to look at this
canonical VAS conjecture is is a stable
lattice sort of for a stable lattice it
turns out that there are no good
projections other than sort of the
determinants of the lattice itself ie
the full projection so you're going to
have to prove something for stable
lattices to begin with and what they
showed in a server beautiful argument is
that the covering radius is bounded by
so this is exactly what you would want
for Conan and Lovaas and this turns out
to be the slicing constant for Voronoi
cells of stable lattices okay and then
they show using this reverse Minkowski
conjecture which I didn't show you that
in fact they can unconditionally bound
this by log end so for general convex
bodies the best thing we have is n to
the 1/4 which is much much bigger than
log n so you know more noise cells are
special somehow good so that's what they
show and then how do they get things for
all lattices so here I'm going to be
super fuzzy
so basically they're going to take an
argument that breaks the lattice up
along its canonical filtration and then
in a very simple way you basically argue
that you know you're covering radius so
now it's l/2 so everything is squared
you're covering radius is upper bounded
by sort of the covering radiuses of the
little blocks and this is sort of
generically true it doesn't matter that
this is a canonical filtration or not
any chain this would be the situation
and then something sort of magical
happens so they're able to bring in this
slicing constant that is related to the
fact that these blocks are stable but
then they have to relate it to the form
that Kanaan and lovest is looking for
which is basically a projection of the
entire lattice so these are little
blocks which is not what we're
for but instead we're looking at
projections of the entire lattice and
when you do that you get this extra log
n factor that shows up all right and
this is exactly what what Kanaan all of
us we're looking for so this the square
root of this is the bound that you get
so that's log into the two point three
point five to one point five okay so
what do I show the last five minutes I
have so this is one first result is we
can do this argument again but sort of
stopped earlier so you do sort of what
you would hope to be able to do which is
sort of directly use the fact that these
are stable and use the bound that reg EV
and the video it showed for each stable
block and then it turns out that you can
just stop there so what does that mean
that means that what I have here is in
fact a lower bound on the covering
radius and this is sort of a new form of
the certificate for the covering radius
and more generally the statement is so
it doesn't matter if you have sort of
this canonical filtration if you have
any chain of sub lattices and you have
that the sort of corresponding slopes
have this increasing property then you
get the following lower bound so you can
basically chain information that you get
from all the blocks as opposed to using
one block and I'm not going to tell you
the proof of this but I will say that
you know to get this lower bound I use
from previous work a semi definite
program relaxation that gives me lower
bounds for the covering radius and I
show that any chain of that form can be
with increasing slopes can be turned
into a feasible solution so they're
supposed to be continuous relaxation so
I said semi definite program good all
right so what's the absolute last part
if you aren't completely lost already so
we want to find these good projections
efficiently okay efficiently means
single exponential time and it turns out
that to do this you kind of need an
approximate notion
this canonical filtration which I'm not
going to get into but well I will say a
few words about is the sort of key
sub-problem which is trying to find
dense lattice subspaces okay so
basically I want to find the sub lattice
non trivial that has approximately
minimal normalized determinants so I'm
particularly I have no idea what rank
this sub lattices and if you look at the
picture what I'm trying to do is find
sort of a sub lattice that has
essentially the minimum slope in this
that is approximately the minimum slope
so what is the very very vague okay no
not high-level idea yeah so what's the
statement so the statement is that we
can compute this up to a login factor
okay so login approximate minimizer's
and single exponential time and what's
the very vague idea and I'll say a
little bit more is that basically if I
start I'm going to start with my guest
being the full lattice and if it turns
out that it's not an approximate
minimizer then I'm going to learn a you
know quartet mentioned one sub lattice
that contains the minimizer and I'm
gonna do this by sampling the discrete
Gaussian from the dual lattice so let me
tell you what just at least the discrete
Gaussian is so the discrete Gaussian is
this beautiful discrete distribution
over a lattice and it has a parameter
and it looks like a Gaussian and if you
make the parameter smaller you get
smaller vectors you get shorter vectors
so somehow getting short vectors is
generically useful thing and it will
also be useful here and the important
thing about the discrete Gaussian is
that we can actually sample it in single
exponential time for any parameter s so
how do we use this so I mentioned that I
need to use the dual lattice so what on
earth is a dual lattice it's just
everybody that has integer inner
products with the original lattice so if
you do lattice points just give you kind
of hyperplanes that lattice hyperplanes
which makes sense if I'm trying to
reduce dimension by one and the you know
so if you start with the integer lattice
the
you never hear about duels is because
the dual of the introducer lattices
itself two minutes good and whatever
whatever yeah so what what is the the
sort of algorithm to find my dense
lattice subspace
I sort of guessed the minimum
determinant I check to see if my current
determinant is too big or is sorry if
it's the right size I return it if it's
too big I sample from the discrete
Gaussian and I repeat on co dimension
one sub lattice okay and the key point
is that you're the vector that you
sample is going to be orthogonal to the
space that you're trying to find with
high probability and to analyze that we
need the reverse Mankowski theorem which
I will tell you about in the last two
slides so what did Minkowski say in 1889
paraphrasing he said if I have a lattice
that has determinant less than 1 and I
look at you know a radius of about
square root and he showed a lower bound
that you basically have an exponential
number of points that about radius and
this is because the ball of volume
square root n of radius square root n
has exponential volume in dimension so
you can specialize that a little bit and
notice that he also says something if
you have sub lattices of low determined
so if you have a sub lattice that has
determined less than 1 and it's
dimension is K that in fact you can show
that you have exponentially K number of
points a distance root K so this is just
the trivial thing by applying
minkowski's theorem to the sub lattice
so what is the the conjecture the sort
of reversal of that so the question is
if all the non-trivial sub lattices of L
have determined at least 1 is this an
upper bound as opposed to a lower bound
and the answer is yes except that you
have this extra logarithmic term and
this is essentially tight for the
integer lattice ok I'm done
[Applause]
I mean you you you take Zen and scale
one vector down or something by a little
bit that's it yeah yeah stable yeah it's
it's a in today yeah it's not a robust
thing in that way other questions
so the I have a question this cannot do
a conjecture for ellipsoids I mean the
the bonds that are proven there they
also give better let's say better than n
to the N time algorithms for the closest
vector yeah let me think not obviously
unfortunately and the reason is because
this enumeration step that I that I use
needs exponential space only point
numbers based and M to the N astilbe
yeah n to the end no matter what you do
is still the best though we know yeah
thank you Thanks
[Applause]